Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
so James Gunn drop the bomb recently said
that he'd been offered DC films in the
Justice League universe
Post Christopher Nolan this going to be a breakdown of that. He also talked about DC films
that he was interested in doing.
He didn't confirm exactly when he was offered this
DC movie like, when this is all taking
place but this twit offers
like a little clarification
you know it might have been after
guardians of the galaxy,
putting it well past the time when they would have
already started putting batman vs
superman in motion, as well as suicide
squad
so I don't think it was those films and because James Gunn is so good at working with misfit characters,
I really feel like it would be green lanterns
that was probably the movie that he was offered
because there was
such a stigma attached to the movie
after it bombed in 2011 one of the big reasons
why it has remained off of DC's big promotional schedule
is because it's so far off and so separated
from what's going on in the Justice League movies
right now.
But it is connected to justice League
we'll see Hal Jordan in other Green
Lantern's with Justice League eventually
it's just that in addition to that movie
being really hard to nail
for any director, you have like the added baggage
of what happened with it in 2011
so they just want to put some distance between
that, so I think considering that James Gunn
would have been making guardians of the galaxy trilogy, like if that movie
blew up and they're like 'oh my God look
at what he did with these misfit characters'
'that nobody cared about
before he made everybody care about them'
and it almost made a billion dollars, 'okay we need to have him do this for some of our characters.'
but he's probably
going to make a trilogy
so that's why Green Lantern's probably so far off
they just wanted to help people forget
about the last movie and give him time
to make his guardians of the galaxy
trilogy
the third guardians movie hasn't come out yet but I would expect it within about two years
of the release of the second guardians movie which is next year, 2017 so sometime in 2019 or 2020
we'll see that third guardians movie.
Marvel's probably going to shuffle the release dates
of a couple films and phase four just based on the success of a lot of the new characters movies in phase 3
like we have dr. strange, we have black panther,
we have Captain Marvel
if someof those movies really blow up, like book way bigger or do way worse than they expect
then they'll just shuffle dates a little
bit but his sensational is all this sounds
like oh my god the idea of James
Gunn directing a DC film that's crazy
I would love to see James Gunn's take on
DC characters you have to remember that
there's just like a certain small group
of Directors in Hollywood that are just like A game
anything that they touch
turns into an awesome movie like
Christopher Nolan is the best example
that he came out of the dark knight trilogy
being able to do anything that he wanted, one of the most powerful Directors in Hollywood
so when you have
repeat big giant hits like it seems
James Gunn is going to have with
guardians of the galaxy 2
like with the big Guardians franchise you get a lot
more people just banging on your door
asking for help because everybody wants
a franchise,
every studio wants the regularity of profits that franchise brings,
so if you're an amazing director, who can tell really amazing stories with any group of misfit characters
you're just like the hot girl in high school
everybody wants to go out with you so
this is really a testament to james gunn
being super-awesome but then he went on
to say that obviously he declined
because he's too busy with guardians and
the characters that they offered him
which may or may not have been Green
Lantern's just weren't that interesting
to him the characters that he talks
about being really interested in like
swamp thing
Shazam, Metal Men they're already like
misfit characters that aren't super popular
like you have batman, superman
they're good examples of the most popular characters
everybody wants to
write a Batman story
James Gunn seems to be more interested in the really weird characters that nobody cares about
so naturally DC properly is it as excited
to make one of those movies like
they want to make the really big character
movies first which is a totally normal thing
but they do have a release
schedule that they want to hit
so based on the time the DC wanted to make this
movie like the release date they wanted to hit
and the time that James Gunn had
available and the characters they were offering
he said that he had to decline
but i do like I just love the idea of a
James Gunn Swamp Thing movie or even
like metalman, metalman are a super deep cut
but let me know in the comments
which movie do you think that he was offered
you think those green lanterns
or do you think that it was something else
do you think it was like a single character movie
I just feel like it was a big ensemble team up movie
and which movie would you want to see James Gunn  do if you were to do a DC movie
I feel like swamp thing everybody wants a
swamp thing movie so if that's gonna be the one we do
that would be the one I want James going to do
but just to explain
why i don't think that he was offered
justice league or some of the more recent films
that are coming out really, I feel like Zack Snyder had already been hired to do man of steel
and he's part of the moderate success of that film
he was offered batman vs superman
they wanted to get the ball rolling
because that started out as a Superman
sequel but then kind of got turned into
a batman movie with Superman in it in
the plant sprawled into the big justice league
10 film release schedule so all
that happened after Man of Steel had come out
so their plans changed really
quickly and obviously they've already changed again
because of all the stuff
is going behind the scenes with geoff johns
becoming the new Kevin Feige
DC films but they already had this very clear vision
of what they wanted with
batman vs superman, Justice League
Suicide Squad was kind of like this one
thing off by itself and because David Ayer
only had about six weeks to work on the
Suicide Squad script I feel like that
you know there's not enough time for
that to have worked out for James Gunn
to have been offered it after guardians
of the galaxy like he was pretty much guaranteed
to be working on the Guardian
sequel when they were starting work on suicide squad
so that's why I feel like
justice league was always going to be a
zack snyder film although it is really
interesting to think about james gunn
directing a justice league movie but
what's gonna happen next is in the
Marvel vs. they've talked about punisher
season one that netflix looks like it's
a revealed that it's coming out at 2017
so i'll be doing a video about that next
so be sure to subscribe to get that
congratulations to the DC giveaway
winner Joshua you win a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so i can get
your contact details there is a new
round of the giveaway that starts now
I don't talk about james gunn whose
Marvel but technically this is a DC
video but all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video they'll probably my next DC video
will probably be flash season three of
my next video today will be punished
season 1 so that should post later
tonight when you guys with the post you
can click here for my guardians of the
galaxy two
a little breakdown from comic-con and
you can click here to learn all about
Henry Cavill's black Superman costume
and justice league
Thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five!
I'll see you guys
tonight